Villains, villains, and more villains.
Every year, New York Comic Con offers interesting
glimpses into the not-so-distant future of
entertainment.
This year, "Star Trek" fans have more than
a little to be happy about, thanks to a new
teaser trailer for the upcoming "Star Trek:
Picard" Season 3.
The brand new New York Comic Con teaser for
the new "Picard" season revolves around a
shocking distress call Admiral Jean-Luc Picard
receives from Beverly Crusher, and an extra-threatening
villain known as Vadic.
However, that's just the beginning of Picard's
troubles this time around.
Even by "Star Trek: Picard" standards, there
are some extremely intriguing character reveals
here, and they have fans all saying the same
thing.
Professor James Moriarty makes his grand entrance
in the teaser saying "Greetings, old friends,"
armed with a smirk, an icy-cold stare, and
a gun.
The hologram Sherlock Holmes villain from
"Star Trek: The Next Generation" isn't the
only bad guy from the show to reemerge in
the Season 3 teaser, either.
Just when you thought everything was over,
Lore stares down the heroes with an extremely
unamused look on his face.
Fans have reacted to the news of the villains'
return with a combination of surprise and
delighted intrigue.
One redditor wrote about Moriarty,
"That was a TNG villain I would have never
guessed about coming back at this point."
Another agreed, saying,
"Moriarty is my favorite character from Star
Trek so you can only imagine my reaction when
he appeared.
I would have never expected that."
Lore drew similar comments from fans.
A Reddit commenter wrote,
"I called 'where is Lore' before the first
season came out...didn't think it would actually
pan out."
Other corners of the internet also took note
of the villain reveals.
A YouTube commenter wrote,
"Holy s—.
Moriarty and Lore.
Hopefully this will be the send off the TNG
crew so rightly deserves."
Meanwhile, over on Twitter, one user couldn't
hide their exclamation mark-heavy excitement,
writing,
"O.M.G!!!!!!
Just watched the trailer for Picard season
3 ! Moriarty & Lore are back!!!!!!!
I can hardly wait!"
Both returning villains have deep ties to
"Star Trek: The Next Generation" protagonists.
The "Star Trek" version of James Moriarty
is actually a highly ambitious hologram that
was originally created by Geordi La Forge,
but soon becomes a self-aware bad guy.
Meanwhile, Lore is Data's fellow Soong-type
android who's ... well, significantly less
friendly than his more famous compatriot.
While neither Moriarty nor Lore are one-and-done
villain of the week types, they both have
but a small handful of episodes under their
belts — two for Moriarty, and four for Lore.
As such, they're both known enemies that longtime
fans can get excited about, yet easily deep
enough cuts to offer all sorts of fascinating
options for "Picard" Season 3.
Judging by their ominous stares in the trailer,
everyone who gets in their way is definitely
in for a deliciously bad time.
The return of these old villains continues
"Picard's" all but stated mission to revisit
the vast majority of "The Next Generation"
characters, minor and major alike — and
in Lore's case, Spiner's continued tendency
to constantly portray new characters in the
show.
How the evil android and the hologram Napoleon
of Crime fit in the grand scheme of things
remains to be seen, but fans can already rest
assured that "Picard" Season 3 will feature
a pretty neat rogues gallery.